action
what happened he just wants to pretend
like he knows about cam he wants to try
to look good
on camera and it's not working no but
bart's like halfway he's literally out
of the screen half the time
see bart you're holding up the shoe
you're holding up the chute bart
but then but then now you're ruining the
angles and like the framing for each one
yeah and dean me or see bart i mean both
of y'all me and joey ain't having a
problem
no we're cool and tiff are perfect
because we have too much protein on this
side no means you can't fit in the frame
oh is that work that's [ __ ] up oh and
you gave it to me
by the way you look so small
[Music]
what do you guys think is happening here
so first of all what do you see sumo
wrestlers
mayonnaise oh yes diaper festival
no sumo wrestlers are is a correct
answer that's awesome how's the sidewalk
not cracking over there
because they're that heavy mayonnaise
you guys ever watched wwf
you ever see that yokozuna yeah he was
like a legit sumo wrestler
yeah i don't know how strong
she versus yokozuna going on right now i
remember him dude yokozuna versus
earthquake remember that [ __ ] i remember
earthquake
i watched that [ __ ] i don't remember
live live yeah what you actually went to
the shows
no no no on tv i went to one i couldn't
i couldn't pay for that [ __ ]
i was one live was it fun it was [ __ ]
fun because i heard the energy in the
room is insane
dog i went with like a group of my
homies in junior highs like eighth grade
and it wasn't on tv but it was just you
know traveling show
and um to be there in the stadium full
of people
seeing the [ __ ] slogans with like you
know because the rock
said so and [ __ ] do you a smell
and everyone's like oh wait wait wait
wait real quick can i take this back
real quick spits water out
i mixed up the slogans i said because
the rock said so and it's because stone
cold said so
i tried to help you thank you yes yes
yes yeah one of my favorite gifs of all
time is a guy at the wwe
uh wwe thing and he salutes
he's like he's like and then he drinks a
beer who's that
some guy in the crowd something's
happening on the stage i think they're
doing the national anthem oh they do do
that a lot and he salutes and then he
drinks a beer immediately afterwards
it's [ __ ] great and they caught the
guy candid
it's fantastic well this has nothing to
do with wwe wwj
or yes japan maybe tea because it's in
tokyo or s because it's sumo wbjts
all right what would jesus tell santa
sjw sjw there it is
okay wrestling japanese japan wrestling
yes anyway so
uh this woman she didn't get gained by
gang banged by all of them
getting gang by the gang bang but you
both can't say it
it it depends on how many people
experts no yeah we're looking for the
gaming experts julia we're doing
something wrong
are we all day today it's getting
progressively more and more like
that's the that's the bit unfortunately
what's happening here i don't think we
did anything wrong
game thing's nothing wrong it's like
wrong game again wrong it's like we
approve it for you guys we're not
setting up for ourselves enough
sexually empowering we're laying down
and taking it julian i mean like what
about you guys have you guys
have you guys participated we don't
watch this if four girls wanted to baby
you know i had to [ __ ] i had to
[ __ ] take it or would you bring a
girl with like 10 other guys yeah no
see anyway moving on all right so tell
us about this lady again get banned
a woman in her 30s was walking near this
river
in tokyo and that's when she i
feel like i could tell where it's going
did she get bumped into the river on
accident
no no no i think it's going to be sad oh
you read it
i did not read it i'm reading context
clues
and body language well then whose body's
language her body language
oh because i'm like trying to like yeah
she's trying to keep it together let's
stop interrupting okay
well i thought she was making fun of
sumo stop interrupts but i thought i was
ready to [ __ ] checker
i want to hear the story i'm trying to
get away from the story that became the
nuke amsterdam
listen how you guys are feeling is how i
feel
i got you i know exactly how you feel i
do not miss this
rj k news you need to be [ __ ] up
before we hear the sad parts that's fair
yeah let the gangbang expert speak
okay anyway back to the story serious
mode all right
so she's stepping out onto a pedestrian
bridge
that spans the river she climbed over
the chest high railing and threw herself
into the water below in an apparent
suicide attempt
that's not funny that's why i said what
the hell too did they say it was funny
you did say hey this could be
lighthearted there's a happy ending you
didn't say that
i didn't say it on camera does the sumo
guy jump in after her and then he sinks
uh and then they have to
try to get him or hits her dude
i thought for a second you were gonna
say the supervisors jump in and create a
big wave in him push your other like oh
[ __ ] i thought that's a huge thing all i
know how to do is push the guy out of a
circle oh [ __ ] i got them
tile okay oh they are no they have a lot
of endurance okay so the time was just
after 5 30 in the morning
uh the bridge is located in a pretty
calm
neighborhood like part of the
neighborhood but luckily
a 70-something-year-old resident local
resident
saw the woman fall into the water and
yelled at her don't
die and then he starts like whipping out
his phone trying to call the paramedics
and it turns out that the closest
building to that
that woman just so happens to be a
dermatory slash training facility for
sumo wrestlers oh [ __ ]
so there were about 20 wrestlers
who rushed to go save the woman who
appeared to be drowning
um so they were able to pull her out of
the water i think that's scarier than
drowning as tony stewart
jumping on top of you no dude they all
made a chain of sumo wrestlers
yeah so they they jumped in there try uh
they did save her they brought her to
like dry land
um pissed but then when the ambulance
arrived
the paramedics they brought down a
stretcher to the mink of the river and
they placed a woman on it
but there was a 6.6 foot barricade
between the bank and
street level so it was really difficult
for only the paramedics to bring up the
woman so then that's when the sumo
wrestlers
combined their strength and they lift
the woman up
onto the road which then she was taken
into the ambulance ambulance and then
taken to the hospital
and so later the doctors reported that
the woman suffered no serious injuries
but the local police precinct they are
considering a certificate of
uh commendation commendation for the
wrestlers
as well as that 70-something year old
man who first noticed the woman jumping
um
and that's it well that's nice that's
really cool yeah it's awesome
i wish there was video of it i know i
only have that photo watch the super
brussels jumping in the water dude the
splashes would be
nuts or maybe they all couldn't swim and
they were all just like connected you
know what i'm saying oh that's cool
twice because they didn't hear it the
first time i just wanted the visual out
there
which part um where they all they all
hold hands and connected to it you love
it
i heard the first time or what if they
all held hands and then they created a
chain that's lame
yeah if you're a super wrestler and you
just jump in the water is that always a
belly flop
but they're so like athletic whether
they dive like perfectly
and you didn't have a peach point
like just one little drop those fools
are like 400
pounds yeah they're biggest
professionally bro i don't know how they
ran there
they can run too but like all in
formation they're really fast
or imagine how much water shot out when
you did this to their belly buttons
afterwards
oh
i'd be tired it's like that she couldn't
get up there right so they put on her
stomach and they oh i'm pulling
and then oh and then bounce her to the
shoulder
they all go bowing on each other yeah
like a gang bang
oh my gosh we're back to that full
circle like a sumo wrestler
how close were we though to a real gang
being huh what
was two games
what's this new branding now that we're
[ __ ] uh
we're trying to pitch your guys's only
fans get you guys some fans there we're
trying to be 13 year old boys around you
guys not big
boys just go jerk off somewhere else
all these girls gonna
like this video is like the first one
that comes out they have no context for
the rest of the day
i think i'm gonna make it funnier the
patreon people get us yeah
the rest of them sorry
you're missing out i don't get it you
guys watched the sumo wrestling
tournament
match when you went to yeah we did that
and then david wrestled with one of them
for real yeah
amazing sumo suit you get wrecked
immediately
yes it was he was terrified it's um
they don't really go like hard
one-on-one but it was kind of like
try to hurt me you couldn't even get him
you see david like
kind of rushed in and like push and this
guy's a retired guy so he's not even
like in his best
shape and he's just standing there and
david couldn't even move him like he's
just standing there yeah
i did i went to fabrico where doom's gym
yeah
and i uh for a video years ago for my
trolling channel that's tight
i had one of his students with his best
student
kick me in the stomach and he normally
wouldn't have done it but he said that i
just talked so much [ __ ] that he had to
yeah
and i talked so much [ __ ] to this guy at
one point i actually had a
guy come out one of my producers come
out and i offered him to wear
some i said you should wear like some
shoulder pad like like a petticoat or
something like some barbara bush
shoulder pad [ __ ]
and he couldn't handle it and he [ __ ]
kicked me in the stomach
so hard that my entire body just [ __ ]
collapsed oh
[ __ ] and the next day were you ready for
it
it wasn't out of nowhere right it's like
okay i'm gonna do you have any sort of
pet i didn't know he's gonna go that
hard
because i didn't know somebody but it
wasn't like he just raged out and kicked
you he was like no no
i was like come kick me bro let's go and
i had a hat okay and he [ __ ]
the foot breached the pad at the bottom
oh and he connected with my ribs
and i was like oh god [ __ ] a diary
and like you could see the kick because
i played it like four times in a row
and uh the next morning that i woke up
i remember leaning up and i had a dog at
the time and my dog breaks and never saw
her again it's fine
oh break up but it's fine i remember
leaning up and i couldn't even
[ __ ] get up while riggs was licking
my face and i just had to lay there and
take it
god is this all still on youtube yeah
it's on youtube it's on youtube
and this wasn't even fabricio's kick
it's his best student he's his student
yeah wow
that's what you get it was so great i
was so happy about it but i was so
[ __ ] sad about it at the same time
really getting pain was just like i'll
have the content
yeah good content oh i see why people
could [ __ ] themselves i'm so glad i went
two hours before
like that kind of [ __ ] yeah it's just
crazy because like the more and more we
think about it like
would people actually do like a gang
bang on this channel
you know what i'm saying yeah okay
[Laughter]
that was three that was tight
[Music]
[Music]
you